we have welcome to fentanyl Island a
drug infested homeless in Canada right
in the middle of Oakland the place looks
like something out of a Mad Max movie it
is littered with scrap metal use needles
and dozens of burnt out cars and it's
not uncommon to see active fires and
dead bodies
sadly Oakland has become Ground Zero for
America's homeless crisis it has the
highest rate of homelessness in the
entire country with over 10 000 people
on the streets
Jesse talked to a local activist about
the lawlessness
dead bodies have been found multiple
times and burnt out Vehicles sometimes
fathers that have been sitting there for
days unreported so what we're seeing
here are places that have become
bash stations of human trafficking and
rampant drug sale and they've been
allowed to Exist by the city while male
gas likes us that things are not as bad
as we believe them to be
Jesse what was it uh did he give you a
sense that you ask about like number one
not only why but what can we do to end
this I mean this encampment here I mean
we shouldn't be supporting this it
sounds like it almost like supported a
bit
will the mayor of Oakland has watched
this Decay and they have spent 120
million dollars a year over the last
five years and the population of
homeless have doubled wow in Oakland so
they're actually spending money to
increase homelessness and they give the
money to these non-profits and then the
money disappears so you give them money
to operation dignity they were supposed
to build cabins got a 60 million dollar
contract no one went to The Cabins
cabins are all dead and they did an
audit and no one can find out where the
paperwork is it's probably in that fire
so there's toxic fumes emanating from
fentanyl Island there's dead bodies and
cartels now control all the drug sales
in and out of the islands
Gavin Newsom it's right under his nose
he doesn't say anything about it the
mayor of Oakland's probably talking
about reparations this is what happens
when you just take this hands off
anything goes approach and give drug
addicts needles and legalize everything
so that was they actually gave the
people drugs and encouraged them to live
decriminalized almost every narcotic and
they have free needles all over the city
Dana well having walked around this city
for the past couple of days and it's not
just today and but it's it's everywhere
at least here it's like it's on all the
doorways of all the stores and on the on
the side of the street and I just think
I cannot believe that we are not dealing
with this and it's not just happening in
New York it's DC it's Denver it's
Seattle St Louis small towns in Colorado
that are having this problem not as big
as fentanyl but certainly homelessness
at first when I read this headline this
morning that we were going to do this
topic I was like oh it's maybe not not a
terrible idea to put all the fentanyl
use on one Island right and like let
that just be an island and let them hash
that out but this is I can't believe
it's 120 million dollars a year and that
you you look at this kind of Destruction
for your tax dollars meanwhile K-12
education is terrible
um I I think we have some serious
problems in the country like letting
people just lay out in the street in
their own filth well commuters and walk
and workers are going by all day long
that
absolutely unacceptable and people are
either going to move or they have to do
something quickly I don't know what they
could do exclamation well you know uh I
have a
the present situation I think is pretty
clear isn't sustainable and I think
there's a dark cynicism that's running
among the leaders in a lot of cities
that the problem will solve itself
they'll just die when you uh uh there
isn't so as much of a worry about
violence with these drugs because if you
walk down the street these people cannot
move it's not like the crack epidemic
where you had a lot of high energy
felons
a lot of robberies in this case these
guys can't even move and they're mostly
guys it's amazing when you walk up Sixth
Avenue I've talked to you about this you
see two things that strike you the
amount of women at lunch going to their
pilates class in Lululemon walking right
past these half dead zombies without a
care in the world and if you're walking
up Sixth Avenue of your choice you
notice this it's incredible because
they're roughly in the same age one went
this way one went that way one's healthy
one is basically on a slow boat to
Suicide that's what this really is as a
concept I am okay with an island profit
and and let them fulfill the fentanyl
fantasy with clean drugs because from a
compassionate standpoint dying on the
street is a zero but in this case you
get to a five right because you separate
this area away from the law-abiding
citizens that means half of the equation
is solved the the people that have to
deal with uh what's going on in their
front in their in their uh in their
driveways or their walkways that is gone
the fear trying to explain this to a kid
I mean you right now have a a harmful
culture that openly rejects your culture
your norms and your rules currently
living in your town
if this was some crazy outer space alien
you would separate them and then monitor
them and see if you could help them
we're not doing that because I do
believe that they just assume these
people are all going to die maybe they
will but I don't think that's the
solution separating them watching them
getting them treatment what's the
solution give us one I would say
legalization legalization and
decriminalization are not the same thing
decriminalization does nothing about the
the demand or the even the supply of the
drugs all it does is mean you can do the
same bad drug anywhere you want
legalization means you actually attack
the drug and you make it so that it is
safe like any drug you get at a pharmacy
is safe and not only that um you get you
get it away from the criminals and you
don't have people dying on the street
people actually live lives on drugs I
know it's hard to believe but they do
okay well until you break up the
homeless industrial complex this problem
is not going to get solved there's so
much corruption in these cities and
Jesse has covered it well on his show
where people who are homeless get paid
to live on the street and then you have
all these non-profits that are supposed
to be solving this problem by building
shelters having rules they don't and you
still end up with this problem all over
the city not just in the shelters or in
very specific areas I agree there should
be a certain area where if you want to
do drugs and you want to be unfentional
that's fine but you don't get to leave
once you sign up like that's where you
live and until you can prove that you're
clean and you're not going to go up
Sixth Avenue and lay in the street
that's where you get to be like the rest
of it goes away because people are
dealing with this everywhere and we're
gonna have a solution to it sure you
guys can live over there and until you
decide that this is no longer something
they're going to voice on the rest of
the country in every single town across
America then there's a place for you to
go
would have did that with the races too
everyone on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now